bonsoir à tous merci de votre attention
quelques images voici les faits
marquants de cette nouvelle journée de
guerre les bombardements quasiment
ininterrompue sur bagdad le ministère de
l'information irakien parle de centaines
de blessés et de morts civils l'état
major américain certifie que seuls les
postes commandement sont visés les
troupes au sol
elles poursuivent leur progression vers
la capitale mais le doute s'installe sur
la stratégie américaine
d'autant qu'un nouvel hélicoptère a été
abattu tout à l'heure tommy franks a
voulu rassurer mais l'inquiétude est
réelle les bourses par exemple sont en
chute libre
et du coup c'est saddam hussein qui
plastronnent c'est l'autre image de la
journée le président irakien veut
montrer qu'il est bien vivant
lors d'une apparition à la télévision il
a félicité ses troupes et promis la
victoire impossible bien sûr à
authentifier la guerre qui a forcé la
porte des oscars actrice en noir badge
pacifistes et michael moore qui a
vivement prise à parti de george bush
les grands vainqueurs de la soirée sont
les films chicago et le pianiste
enfin autre actualité en france le plan
contre le cancer annoncé par jacques
chirac 500 millions d'euros sur cinq ans
prévention dépistage et recherche
tout de suite nous allons donc à bagdad
où les phases de répit sont de plus en
plus courte il ya un peu plus d'une
heure et demie
les sirènes ont à nouveau retenti
quatrième raid aérien de la journée
contre la capitale irakienne
on va retrouver dans un instant alain de
chalvron en direct les dernières images
d'abord elles sont commentés par stephen
breitner cinquième jour de guerre
cinquième jour de bombardement sur
bagdad cette fois ci à la périphérie de
la ville
depuis hier soir l'armée américaine ne
laisse aucun répit à la capitale
irakienne
le pilote d'un chasseur bombardier a
même filmé sa mission la nuit dernière
les cibles un palais présidentiel le
centre de télécommunications et des
bâtiments du ministère de la défense
la résistance inattendue des irakiens
oblige l'armée américaine a appuyé ses
troupes au sol par les airs toute la
journée les b52 et des avions de combat
f 117 ont déversé leurs bombes sur tous
les fronts du pays dans les villes du
sud à bassora et naciria au nord à
mossoul et pour la première fois sur la
ligne de démarcation avec le kurdistan
tommy franks commandant des forces de la
coalition s'est adressé à la presse pour
la deuxième fois depuis le début du
conflit
image satellite à l'appui le général
entend prouver la précision des frappes
des flèches bleues montre des bâtiments
intacts
alors que ceux d'un côté sont détruits
nos forces aériennes continuent à
frapper des bâtiments de commandement et
de contrôle du régime ainsi que des
divisions armés dans tout le pays avec
précision et applications la précision
ce n'est pas la vie des irakiens
voilà ce que montre la télévision
officielle depuis le début de la journée
des bâtiments effondrés et les secours
qui travaille pour dégager les victimes
mais il arrive aussi aux soldats
irakiens de ne pas rater leur cible
comme ce drone de l'armée américaine a
battu aujourd'hui qu'ils exhibent comme
un trophée
bonsoir alain de chalvron vous êtes en
direct de bagdad
d'abord le bilan on entend parler de
frappe précise les autorités irakiennes
elle parle de centaines de morts et de
blessés civils avez-vous des indications
on n'a pas d'indication près fils sur le
bilan naturellement les bombardements
sont devenus tellement fréquent
tellement lourd vous avez dit tout à
l'heure qu'on en était à la quatrième
vague de bombardements de la journée
vous savez une
les comptes ont plus il y à des
bombardements sans arrêt il n'y a plus
d' alerte véritablement on bambins de
toutes les parties de la ville le centre
encore tout à l'heure un très fort
bombardements dans la le secteur du
palais présidentiel et toute la banlieue
alors non non c'est difficile à dire
mais c'est certainement certainement des
dizaines voire de centaines de morts ça
ne peut pas être autrement tellement
tellement il y a de bon dans les deux
frappes à droite à gauche dans le centre
dans le sud à l'aise pour tous dans
bagdad alors elle ainsi si la ville est
maintenant bombardés jour et nuit
pratiquement de façon ininterrompue
comment la vie peut-elle continuer
normalement oui côté suit toujours le
paradoxe un peu surréaliste de cette
ville où les gens par la force des
choses vivre maintenant essaye de vivre
normalement
alors au début de la campagne aérienne
évidemment pendant les alertes les gens
restés chez eux ou aller dans des abris
maintenant ce n'est même plus le cas
d'ailleurs il n'y a plus d' alerte il
n'y a plus que les bombardements et
pendant les bombardements la vie
continue il ya toujours de la
circulation alors que l'ambiance a
changé
vous savez que les irakiens ont allumé
des tranchées de pétrole l'air est
chargé de deux suis noirâtre et ça fait
très mal à la gorge et très pénible à
vivre donc la vie n'est plus tout à fait
la même là est devenu difficile mais le
moral est bon
le moral est meilleur depuis que l'on
sait que le bataillon d'une castres a
tenu bon face à l'armada américaine et
anglaise
les irakiens se sentent remontée se
sentent capables d'infliger aux
américains aussi des pertes de se battre
et de se défendre
merci alain on y reviendra dans un
instant vous restez avec nous on va
retrouver un autre de nos envoyés
spéciaux qui vit comme tous les
habitants ces journées de feu et de
alerte chronique de la vie à bagdad ces
dernières 24 heures bertrand cocq
emmanuel bec devant la faculté dalle
moustansiriya le cratère d'une bombe
américaine
des techniciens des télécoms s'active à
réparer des lignes de téléphone sans
panique dans la décontraction
les irakiens ont dû cran ces jours ci
mohamed qui travaillent en face nous
montre ses bureaux dont les vitres ont
volé en éclats lui même ancien élève de
l'université ne comprends pas pourquoi
ici
c'est le souffle de la bombe a ravagé le
club des étudiants selon les officiels
irakiens qui nous accompagnent ce
dommage collatéral aurait fait trois
morts et 26 blessés
ils sont là les blessés sur leur lit
d'hôpital ceux d'hier et ceux
d'aujourd'hui de la souffrance donner en
pâture à la presse internationale dans
un rapport de force qui leur était
favorable
les irakiens se servent de tous et
d'abord des images mais ce drame est
bien réelle un gosse de 15 ans qui perd
son sens un grand frère qui tremble pour
son cadet toutes ces victimes sont
manifestement des civils des femmes des
adolescents certains nous dit-on ont été
extraits d'une maison bombardée dans la
journée à l'heure du déjeuner les
médecins qui parlent anglais s'en
prennent à la légère
donc voilà le travail nous dit celui-là
le soir venu les premières sirènes
d'alert les tirs de décès à sonne le
couvre-feu les rues se vident la ville
se ferme pour la nuit
ce restaurant d'arras hâte le quartier
chic de bagdad a choisi de rester
ouverts mais il ne fait pratiquement
plus que de la livraison
seul le patron tient encore table
ouverte pour ses amis je n'ai pas peur
dit il
les anglais les américains on n'a même
pas besoin d'armes pour les battre on va
les écraser non à tout y est
tandis que son copain en uniforme
d'officier joint le geste à la parole
les nouvelles du front les images des
prisonniers de guerre américain saddam
hussein qui félicite ses commandants les
plus valeureux tout cela agit sur le
moral des irakiens et renforce un
sentiment de fierté nationale
si les américains arriver demain à
bagdad rien ne dit qu'ils seraient
accueillis en libérateurs alors
précisément après la guerre aérienne
l'offensive
au sol les forces américaines dans leur
remontée vers bagdad évité jusque là les
villes une exception peut-être naciria
en début d'après-midi une attaque très
importante a été lancé contre cette cité
de 260 mille habitants située entre
bassorah et la capitale un bataillon de
marines seraient même entrés dans la
ville images commentées par yasmina
farber et françois beaudonnet pas de
temps à perdre pour soigner les blessés
le soldat bernard joshua assurer la
sécurité d'un pont près de nassiriyah il
empêcher les civils de traverser quand
sa section a été mitraillé toute
l'équipe médicale est mobilisée sa vie
le soldat peut rassurer ses proches
je vais bien j'ai été touché à la main
et on m'a opéré autour de nassiriyah un
carrefour stratégique sur l'euphrate à
350 km de bagdad
les combats sont très violents les
soldats irakiens ont tendu des
embuscades meurtrières
il y aurait dix morts et une douzaine de
disparus les marines enveloppe le corps
de l'un d'entre eux dans un drapeau
américain
il sera rapatrié en hélicoptère ici le
risque est omniprésent comme le confier
cet après-midi un photographe de l afp
incorporez chez les marines là où je
suis
juste un paquet il ya une demi-heure par
des irakiens et ce qui est nouveau fait
que deux irakiens ont été tués avaient
des fusils et ils étaient ensuite vide
les soldats américains vivent dans
l'angoissé d'être prise au piège
chantal a tout à l'heure qui rentrait
complètement essoufflé vivaient les
civils qui nous attaque
ça risque d'être comme le vietnam qui
feront pas qui sont les amis qui font
l'événement
pendant que des chars cerne la ville de
nassiriya les troupes américaines
restent très vigilantes aux abords de
l'heure quand elles ont escorté tous
leurs prisonniers de guerre dans le
désert naciria si la bataille a bien
lieu devrait rester un cas isolé la
stratégie américano britannique est
maintenant bien connu concentre l
offensive sur bagdad pour tenter de
faire tomber le régime en espérant que
le reste du pays suivra c'est donc une
immense caravane de chars de camions qui
poursuit son avancée du sud au nord tony
blair a confirmé tout à l'heure que les
premières unités serait à moins de 100
km de bagdad hervé ghesquière
le fer de lance de l'armée américaine la
3e division d'infanterie
elle fonce dans le désert direction
bagdad sont avancés et spectaculaire
mais parfois les blindés doivent
ralentir
il y a des mines qu'il faut neutraliser
sur le bord de la piste des bédouins
salue les gi's de temps à autre il y a
aussi quelques accrochages avec des
groupes armés irakien des hommes sont
faits prisonniers comme à ce point de
contrôle mais rien de très sérieux
nous avons eu des contacts sporadiques
avec l'armée mais elle n'est pas très
organisée c'est vrai nous n'avons pas eu
de réel problème en terme d'engagement
mais nous avons fait quelques prises
pour l'instant l'armée américaine est
vite les difficultés les poches de
résistance dans sa remontée vers le nord
nassiriya et nadjaf sont contournées
dans un premier temps puis encerclés au
sud la deuxième ville d'irak bassorah
résiste depuis trois jours les
britanniques but sur la cité à majorité
chiite
les combats font rage mais une partie
des blindés n'attend pas et remonte déjà
vers le nord et bagdad
ceux qui restent savent qu'il faudra se
battre âprement comme cet officier
britannique
personne ne pensait que ce serait le
même scénario que la dernière guerre du
golfe du problème ici c'est que l'armée
irakienne et sur son propre territoire
et qu'elle va de toute évidence se
battre pour tenter de retarder les
américains les irakiens ont également sa
beauté des oléoducs
mais au qg américain du qatar le général
franks se veut toujours confiant les
résultats sont excellents
le moral est bon et je pense qu'il n'y a
aucun doute sur l'issue de la guerre
mais pour la durée du conflit c'est une
tout autre question les américains
creusent des tranchées de violents
accrochages ont toujours lieu à bassora
deux soldats américains et britanniques
ont été tués un troisième capturé par un
groupe paramilitaire les fedayines de
saddam
enfin le vice premier ministre tarek
aziz affirme que la garde républicaine
combattu à oum cassard et que seules les
troupes régulières sont intervenus une
déclaration en forme d'avertissement le
plus dur reste à venir
et c'est vrai qu'il ya des doutes sur
cette stratégie avant d'y venir un
témoignage d'abord au coeur de ce convoi
celui de notre envoyé spécial agnès
vahramian elle se trouve avec des
marines au nord de naciria direction
bagdad et nous avons pu la joindre par
téléphone tout à leur écoute et nous
sommes dans un convoi de plusieurs
centaines de véhicules avec des camions
du génie transportant des ponts mobiles
de la logistique de l'opération
déchargement d'obus aussi les chars des
véhicules blindés un cordon immense qui
roule à 30 km/heure avec pour consigne
de faire route jour et nuit vers bagdad
tout au long de l'autoroute c'est le
désert sur le bas-côté quelques
carcasses de chars irakien bombardé par
l'aviation quelques fortin fait de terre
de paille de voix des positions déserté
aujourd'hui et maryse avec lui nous
faisons route on les bardes à accrocher
à leur véhicule les traits tirés les
visages couverts de poussière
la route est parsemée des sachets vides
de leurs rations militaires
avec eux nous avons franchi l'euphrate
puis au bout de cette autoroute nous
voulons désormais sur une piste de sable
c'est un décor un peu irréaliste de la
route
nous avons vu des habitants qui
quémandent de l'eau et de la nourriture
certains disent qu'ils sont en colère
des bombardements américains mais
d'autres explique qu'il serait heureux
de vivre sans saddam hussein de la piste
nous voyons les lumières des villes que
les américains contourne soigneusement
leur objectif c'est de constituer un
front vers bagdad
là devant nous encore à 250 km oui et
interrogations depuis hier depuis 36
heures maintenant sur cette stratégie
américaine d'éviter les villes sauf
peut-être naciria il ya très peu de
reddition pas beaucoup de prisonniers
est une vraie résistance irakienne
bonsoir général dannatt à beaufort vous
êtes ancien chef d'état major de l'armée
de l'air question alors pourquoi cette
stratégie les américains ne vont pas
dans les villes
par précaution parce qu'ils veulent
faire le moins de victimes possibles
dans leurs rangs et dans les rangs des
civils irakiens où ils ne vont pas dans
les villes parce que la résistance
irakienne est finalement beaucoup plus
forte que prévu
je pense qu'elle est deux il ya les deux
hypothèses je pense qu initialement
l'hypothèse était de conquérir très
rapidement les villes et que les villes
tomberait les unes après les autres avec
zazie l'américain considéré que ce qui
m'arrive de libérateur ça c'était
l'hypothèse favorable bon on sait on
sait tout de suite aperçu comme quoi
c'est
à bassorah la résistance organisée alors
là les américains ont été obligés de
changer de tactique donc ils sont ils
sont allés vers naciria la même scénario
donc ils ont décidé à ce moment là tout
contourner les villes qui peuvent être
des points résistance ils ont contrôle
ils ont contourné en particulier nadjaf
et kerbala qui sont des villes saintes
dans lesquelles il aurait été impensable
de voir flotter le drapeau américain ou
de faire des destructions si vous voulez
pour aller se présenter devant bagdad
est donc frappé à la tête
mais alors bagdad justement imaginons
qui est 40 50 60 peut-être cent mille
soldats américains qui se massent au
faubourg dans les faubourgs de bagdad
mais que se passera-t-il ensuite parce
qu'on comptait sur ce fameux front nord
avec des troupes venant de turquie
finalement elles sont pas là est ce que
les américains auraient les moyens
d'attaquer bagdad avec ses seules
troupes là je ne pense pas je crois que
le la sphère du front nord pèsera lourd
dans cette guerre je crois que l'échec
diplomatique avec la turquie est quelque
chose qui va avoir des conséquences
importantes sur le plan stratégie de la
stratégie militaire
il manque aux américains cinquante
soixante mille hommes au nord qui aurait
pu descendre sur sur bagdad est fixé en
fin de compte les unités de la garde
républicaine qui sont positionnées au
nord
c'est cette hypothèse était donc à
abandonner en revanche les américains
ont ressemblement une autre possibilité
est là je donne simplement un avis
personnel
c'est de faire une opération aéroportée
sur les terrains du kurdistan de façon à
pré-positionné des troupes qui seront
plus légères mais qui permettront de
fixer un nombre important d'unités on
est quand même en train de nous dire que
vous avez des doutes et que cette
stratégie vous semble hasardeuse non non
je n'irai pas jusque là s'il faut le
moment je n'irai pas jusque là je crois
que les américains savent ce qu'ils font
ils ont ils ont monté une opération est
comme toutes les opérations
les choses ne se déroulent pas toujours
vous savez les guerres hagrid fraîche et
joyeuse l'ours est relativement rare on
n'en connaît pas beaucoup
et donc aujourd'hui c'est obligé
d'adapter leurs
leur tact et alors vous restez avec nous
et on va au qatar trouvait laurent
boussier au quartier général de l'armée
américaine à doha
laurent tommy franks lui le patron des
opérations ne laisse paraître
visiblement aucun doute sur cette
stratégie
il donnait une conférence de presse au
giro avait de la vie tu voulais
absolument d'avis vous savez le discours
aujourd'hui du général tommy franks qui
était avant tout est essentiellement
destinée à l'opinion publique américaine
après les morts et les prisonniers
américains dit alors le message était
clair vous l'avait déjà montré dans les
reportages tout se passe à peu près
comme prévu rien de ce qui se passe sur
le terrain n'était nous surprendre ne
nous étonne l'offensive va à peu près
comme la planification parfois même elle
est un peu en avance
alors pour le c'est vrai la lfh
l'offensive marche à peu près comme il
faut malgré quelques poches de
résistance mais par contre est ce assez
significatif le général frank a été très
discret voire gêné sur deux points qui
sont plus politiques que militaires le
premier vous l'avait déjà évoqué aussi
c'est cette affaire de population la
population n'accueille pas dans la
liesse les soldats américains
et ça c'est une nouveauté c'est presque
un choc pour les américains
s'attendaient à arriver en libérateur
d'où le nom d'ailleurs de leurs
opérations
et puis le deuxième le deuxième point
délicat en ce moment pour le général
franck ce sont les armes de destruction
massive et les armes chimiques pour
l'instant après cinq jours d'offensive
les américains n'ont pas trouvé et les
irakiens n'ont pas tiré
or les armes de destruction massive et
les armes chimiques étaient là la
justification principale de cette guerre
avec l'irak
juste un bon laurent je ne sais pas si
vous avez des indications sur cette
explosion qui a retenti tout à l'heure à
barres entre du siège de la cinquième
flotte américaine avez-vous des détails
et je n'ai malheureusement ici laisse
officier de presse américains ne font
que confirmer après coup les
informations qu'on apprend généralement
par l'a13 par la presse ou pape d'autres
sources au pentagone alors ce temps que
le pentagone n'en parle pas ici on a peu
de chance d'avoir des informations
là-dessus
merci laurent il faut rappeler que cinq
cent mille soldats sont 500 me
d'américains vivent actuellement à
bahreïn où des manifestations contre la
guerre ont été organisées récemment on
n'aura peut-être plus d'indication dans
le courant de ce journal alors
assurances donc côté américain assez
grande assurance de tommy france
vous l'avez dit laurent mai
nouvelle perte largement exploité par la
télévision irakienne celle d'un
hélicoptère apache dans la région de
kerbala à 80 km au sud de bagdad yann
fronty on ne sait toujours pas s'ils
sont morts ou vivants
aucune trace de pilotes sinon leurs deux
casques et ses quelques cartes que
piétine chèrement ses hommes en armes
ces images ont été filmées ce matin par
la télévision irakienne et commenté en
musique par un envoyé très spécial
habillé d'un treillis militaire ces
citoyens courageux de karbala ont abattu
deux avions ennemis
bonjour rade
comment tu as fait pour abattre cet
hélicoptère j'ai entendu le
vrombissement des moteurs
je suis alors sorti avec mes frères et
ma famille nous avons tiré et on les a
eus
cet hélicoptère ne semble pourtant pas
avoir été abattu mais plus victime d'une
défaillance technique
il s'est posé sans avoir le temps de
sortir son train d'atterrissage
il est intact sans une trace d'impact
sur la carlingue
même les missiles sont encore là
qu'importe la cause sa chute c'est une
victoire pour le régime irakien mais ils
ont capturé les pilotes
si c'est possible peut-être qu'on
voulait montrer la prise de cet
hélicoptère est une nouvelle victoire
pour saddam hussein hautement symbolique
est orchestrée comme tel sur place
propagande oblige c'est l'équipe de
télévision qui organise l'effusion de
joie
ces slogans n'ont rien de spontané
l'essentiel est de marquer les esprits
pour toi saddam on sacrifiera notre âme
et notre sang crie la foule
voilà un hélicoptère au sol et puis
image au site de ses premiers soldats
américains blessés en irak
rapatrié sur une base américaine en
allemagne à une centaine de kilomètres
au sud-ouest de francfort 12 blessés
exactement qui se font soigner à
l'hôpital militaire de landstuhl etienne
leenhardt bonsoir alors cette succession
de mauvaises nouvelles entre guillemets
les premiers morts les premiers blessés
les premiers prisonniers les villes qui
résistent a visiblement déstabilisé
labour
wall street est en forte baisse paris a
perdu plus de 5% est ce qu'elle ébranle
aussi cette succession de nouvelles le
moral de l'opinion américaine
côté aucun expert militaire ne parle
pour l'instant d'enlisement on imagine
après seulement cinq jours de guerre le
pentagone rappelle que l'opération a été
budgété sur au moins 30 jours et qu'il a
fallu plus de trois semaines de
bombardements et de combats en
afghanistan même si l'irak et
l'afghanistan ne sont pas directement
comparables avant que le régime des
taliban ne s'effondre ceci dit les
événements de ce week-end pose à un
double problème si je puis dire aux
américains un problème militaire puisque
cette avance est tellement rapide vers
bagdad on l'a bien vu fragilise les
lignes arrières et permet à des petits
groupes d'irakiens et vient de mener des
opérations de guérilla
et puis alors sur le front de l'opinion
publique l'opinion publique je le disais
depuis 48 heures continue de faire
confiance à son commandant en chef à son
président mais on a tellement dit aux
américains que leur armée était
supérieur ultra supérieure sur le plan
technologique et bien que cette
confiance pourrait mais à moyen terme
seulement s'éroder si la stratégie des
militaires américains est remise en
cause non seulement par des soldats tués
mais aussi par des revers sur le terrain
merci etienne quelques détails sur cette
explosion à bahreïn dont je vous parlais
tout à l'heure où 5000 américains vivent
et non pas 500 villes comme je
l'indiquais par erreur et bien elle
s'est produit tout près de la base de
joux faire dans l'émirat de bahreïn qui
abrite la vème flotte américaine on ne
sait pas si c'était à l'intérieur ou à
proximité de la base on aura peut-être
plus de détails dans quelques instants
autre fait marquant de cette journée
cette apparition de saddam hussein à la
télévision à moins évidemment qu'il ne
s'agisse d'un sosie
ce matin encore la presse américaine
affirmé qu'il avait été blessé
eh bien le dire et le dictateur salue la
résistance de son armée la victoire est
proche dit-il florence bukiya pour des
oreilles non averties le second discours
de saddam hussein depuis le début de la
guerre peut sembler grandiloquent c'est
pourtant un véritable discours politique
le raïs espère galvaniser ses troupes
son peuple mais aussi toute l'opinion
arabe
sanglé dans son uniforme militaire
saddam hussein félicite d'abord la
population irakienne et la sueur de la
victoire clusaz il encense les combats
quand particulièrement ceux qui
résistent aux assauts des forces
américano britannique au sud de l'irak
je dis à nos chers compatriotes de basra
la prospère fait le bon sens là je le
redis patiente et cher frère la victoire
est toute proche au sein de la 11ème
division est inquiète
je salue tout particulièrement le 45e
bataillon qui a planté haut le drapeau
et le nom de l'irak dans la bataille de
gaza depuis ce matin certains médias
américains comparé les images de saddam
hussein de jeudi dernier à gauche et de
ce matin à droite et se demande encore
s'il s'agit d'un sosie
c'est cette dame je n'en doute pas
ensuite il a été enregistré il ya pas
longtemps parce qu'il le site des
événements qui sont passés hier
et puis je pense pas qu'il l'ait fait en
direct parce qu'il a toujours une
méfiance terrifiante de la technologie
américaine indirects on peut savoir d'où
vient l'émission est un tournant qui
arrivent aussitôt une nouvelle fois
saddam hussein appelle son peuple à
frapper l'ennemi avec force et précision
ce sont vos jours décisifs aux irakiens
frappé aujourd'hui comme vous l'a
ordonné à l'un rappelle était frappé les
doit frapper votre ennemi et votre
patience entraînera une bonne nouvelle
tout au long de son discours le raïs
fait vibrer la corde sensible de
l'opinion arabe sunnite ou chiite avec
des références au coran et au jihad et
avec une conclusion vive l'irak et vive
la palestine arabe est libre et nous
retournons à bagdad avec vous alain de
chalvron est ce que cette intervention
est susceptible de le souder de
convaincre un peu plus les irakiens est
ce qu elle a été suivie
oui naturellement a été suivie mais
c'est le fun surf sur une vague
cette vague du 45ème bataillon de même
quatre heures qui a résisté
vous n'avez entendu tout à l'heure il
l'a mentionné lui même il a félicité
personnellement nominalement les
officiers de ce bataillon et c'est vrai
que le peuple irakien tout entier suit
et les événements héroïque entre
guillemets de ce bataillon à une caste
alors je crois qu'il ya de moins en
moins une coupure entre disons les pros
saddam minorité du peuple qui serait pro
saddam et une majorité qui serait un
fils adam ou a plus que des irakiens qui
se sentent en vanille et qu'ils veulent
résister regardez ce tract photo tract
de longue date la système qui est le
chef religieux des chiites qui est de
nadjaf qui vient de publier une victoire
qui a été distribuée à 12 millions
d'exemplaires à travers le pays alors
d'ailleurs on ne sait pas s'il l'a
vraiment vraiment signé non pas pour le
moment il n'y a pas de démentis mais en
tout temps c'est le signe que même les
religieux les religieux chiites
pourtant c'était quelqu'un de très
hostile qui a été déjà menacé de mort
par saddam hussein en sa fatwa vit tous
ceux qui aideront les américains iront
pendant faire merci alain la télévision
décidément au coeur de cette guerre
apparition également de tarek aziz il ya
une heure environ toujours la télévision
irakienne
tous les dirigeants irakiens sont sains
et saufs a déclaré le vice premier
ministre lors de cette conférence de
presse ils sont en bonne santé
saddam hussein a le contrôle total de
ses forces armées alors général la natte
à une question
tout de même pourquoi est ce que les
américains n'ont pas détruit la
télévision irakienne où
les les antennes permettant de relayer
la télévision irakienne parce qu'elles
étaient lisses elysées réellement comme
une arme
oui tout à fait je crois que c'est une
question à laquelle il est difficile de
répondre
ils en ont les moyens techniques mais il
peut il peut y avoir déjà un problème
technique parce que on peut il peut y
avoir un réseau d'émetteurs maillet avec
reliés entre eux par des fibres optiques
parce qu'ils ont des fibres optiques les
irakiens je pense que la raison n'est
pas seul il peut y en avoir deux tout
d'abord les émetteurs peuvent être au
milieu de zones urbaines donc plus
qu'une leur destruction risquerait de
créer des dommages collatéraux c'est
important la deuxième qui est né qui me
paraît la plus importante c'est que les
américains avaient vraisemblablement
l'intention d'utiliser ces mêmes réseaux
de télévision très rapidement ouais
comme beaucoup d'infrastructures
irakienne et art que cette cette
propagande à la télévision de saddam
hussein et d'y aider des différents
dirigeants que l'on a pu voir la
télévision maintenant c'est quelque
chose qui est très important pour le
soldat qui est dans son trou et où
derrière son bunker et derrière sa
mitrailleuse séoul et lui en fin de
compte ça exalte le sentiment
nationaliste et je crois qu'on a fait
une erreur en s'imaginant que les
chiites les sunnites ou les kurdes qui
aurait pu se se dissocier si vous voulez
et répondre plus à leur appartenance
religieuse ou autre
classy mon assiette au sentiment
national or je crois que ce sentiment
national et 13 exacerbée longue merci
général la note 'aaa' d'avoir répondu à
nos questions direction les états unis
maintenant depuis hier la guerre offre
cet autre visage son vrai visage celui
de la souffrance avec notamment ces
images de prisonniers américains et
cette polémique sur l'application de la
convention de genève on va y venir dans
un instant d'abord la réaction des
familles là-bas pascal golomer tristan
le braz
c'est en regardant la chaîne de
télévision par satellite des philippines
son pays d'origine
cani sita a reconnu son fils joseph leon
23 ans
quand je les ai vus ça avait l'air
d'aller mais je connais mon fils il part
à ceux ci et frier aux journalistes qui
se succèdent dans son salon depuis hier
elle répète qu'elle n'a eu aucune
information des autorités américaines
mais elle garde espoir
je veux juste qu'ils rentrent à la
maison
j'espère que le président bush va tout
essayer pour faire sortir ces
prisonniers pas seulement mon fils n'est
tout le monde
joseph et sonne comme tous ceux qui ont
été capturés ou tués à naciria vient de
fort bliss au texas
rien à voir avec une unité commando il
s'agit d'une compagnie chargée de la
maintenance du matériel
aussi quand kimberley miller découvre le
visage de son frère patrick sur un site
internet
elle a peine à y croire cela m'a
bouleversé
je ne pensais pas que ça pouvait être
mon frère pourtant c'était bien lui et
c'était terrible même maintenant
j'essaie de rester optimiste il aurait
pu être tuée plutôt que d'être fait
prisonnier
mais pour des dizaines de milliers de
familles américaines qui ont un proche
sur le terrain et qui suivent cette
guerre heure par heure à la télévision
l'attenté depuis ce week-end un peu plus
éprouvant encore alors les dirigeants
irakiens at il violé la convention sur
les prisonniers que dit exactement ce
texte richard binet lorsque donald
rumsfeld découvre au cours d'un
entretien sur la chaîne américaine cbs
les premières images de gi's prisonniers
sa réaction est immédiate
la convention de genève indique
clairement qu'il est interdit de
photographier ou du vivier des
prisonniers en termes de droit
international
le ministre de la défense a raison
l'article 13 de la convention de 1949
stipule les prisonniers de guerre
doivent être protégés en tout temps
notamment contre tout acte de violence
ou d'intimidation contre les insultes et
la curiosité publique
ces images de gi's prisonniers
interrogés par la télévision irakienne
les américains ne les verront pas ou
presque la majorité des networks ont
choisi pour leurs boys de suivre les
consignes gouvernementales et de ne pas
les diffuser
en revanche ils n'hésiteront pas à
montrer leur propre prisonniers les
mains sur la tête une position pourtant
considérée comme humiliante par la
fédération des droits de l'homme six
matches qui nous sont montrés d'un côté
ou l'autre entre prisonniers de guerre
sont détestables puisque les
instrumentalisent des victimes
en ce qui concerne pour le reste la
vérité et les deux poids deux mesures je
constate que les américains ne se sont
jamais embarrassé depuis longtemps
notamment en aghanistan can am ou du
respect de la convention de genève
je suis heureux qu'il a re découvre
aujourd'hui depuis le début du conflit à
france 2 nous sommes tenus à ne rien
cacher de la réalité de cette guerre que
ce soit avec les prisonniers ou avec les
morts qu'il soit anglais américains et
irakiens avec le souci d'informer son
tomber dans le voyeurisme
nous avons donc souvent supprimer les
images les plus violentes
nous allons maintenant dans le nord de
l'irak dans le kurdistan autonome car la
tension est en train de monter là aussi
très vite ce n'est plus seulement la
rumeur de la guerre mais peut-être déjà
la guerre elle-même incursion irakienne
bombardements américains sur la ligne de
démarcation est arrivée de nouvelles
forces spéciales reportage de nos
envoyés spéciaux vincent nguyen gilles
jacquier ce sont les premières images de
forces spéciales américaines dans une
base du kurdistan irakien en tenue de
camouflage sable ou kaki ses hommes
roulant tout terrain civils dont
beaucoup ôta rectangle orange collé sur
le toit
l'endroit où nous les avons filmé
appartient à l'armée du parti
démocratique kurde
les autorités ne cache plus qu'elle
travaille avec les états unis dans le
cadre de la coalition
et l'arrivée d'un nombre important de
forces spéciales hier a été
officiellement annoncé on parle
d'environ 300 hommes mais on ignore
combien étaient déjà sur le terrain en
secret il reste extrêmement discret
d'ailleurs les cures de gardien de la
base empêche quiconque d'approcher avec
une caméra pour expliquer la mission de
ces américains un officier a fait
aujourd'hui sa première apparition
publique au kurdistan selon le général
osmane leur rôle sera de coordonner les
opérations militaires et humanitaires et
d'assurer la stabilité de la région en
préservant les frontières actuelles de
l'irak un avertissement clair à la
turquie en revanche pas un mot sur
l'ouverture éventuelle d'un front nord
quelques forces spéciales seraient déjà
à la frontière entre l'irak des kurdes
et celui de saddam
on y voit pour l'instant que des pêches
merga cela se rendre au village kurde de
chercheurs ouanna ce matin les irakiens
se serait approché en tirant à la
mitrailleuse et ses hommes en armes
viennent en renfort
mais les habitants ne sont pas vraiment
celui ci nous dit qu'il emmène sa
famille à l'abri parce que la guerre
approche qui a peur fille c'est sûr que
les soldats irakiens tireront sur les
militaires comme les civils sans
distinction
la situation est tendue le long de la
frontière et l'avenir est incertain
depuis hier les américains ayant
bombardé trois positions irakienne la
dernière fois c'était à 15 kilomètres
d'ici
c'est aujourd'hui vers midi il ya eu des
bons par là bas j'ai entendu des
explosions de ce côté et il y avait des
avions
ces bombardements sont ils les prémices
d'une guerre au nord de l'irak
les kurdes de la région attendent de le
savoir tout près de la frontière à
chamchamal autre envoyé spécial jérôme
boni jérôme peut-on dire qu'un deuxième
front est en train de s'ouvrir au nord
on peut imaginer david que ce sont les
préparatifs d'un deuxième fois en effet
ces bombardements aussi bien sûr
chamchamal qui est près de kirkouk que
plus à l'ouest dans la région de mossoul
ces bombardements américains sur les
lignes irakienne devrait être les
éléments précurseurs peut-être d'une
intervention au sol
car il est évident que cela constitue un
élément qui déstabilise la situation
tout à l'heure il y avait une conférence
de presse du chef de la sûreté de
l'union patriotique du kurdistan
le docteur rouleau qui nous disait qu'
il était en fait en face de deux menaces
celle des irakiens d'un côté et puis
celle des islamistes de l'autre dans
cette région qui est proche de la
frontière avec l'iran vous savez que
cette région a été abondamment bombardé
pendant plusieurs nuits et que ces
islamistes certains d'entre eux ont été
tuées et une centaine d'autres se sont
réfugiés dans les montagnes et d'autres
se sont dispersés dans le pays dans le
kurdistan irakien et notamment dans la
ville de suleimanieh dont je vous parle
en ce moment alors bien sûr cette
situation de guerre qui touchent aussi
un petit peu le kurdistan irakien
et bien elle a tendance à inquiéter les
autorités locales et et ce chef de la
sûreté nous disait qu'il accueillerait
bien sûr avec bienveillance et
soulagement
toute intervention étrangère ici en fait
les troupes américaines qui pourraient
véritablement constituer un front nord
sont attendus avec une certaine
impatience
merci jérôme depuis longtemps
s'interroge également sur l'après guerre
la presse adam et bien et bien depuis le
début de l'offensive l'opposition
irakienne croient plus que jamais la
chute du régime
elle est en train de se rassembler en
jordanie envoyé spécial à man loïc de la
mornais joseph ans dans un appartement
anonyme dans un quartier résidentiel
dahmane
fouille minutieuse il nous a fallu
plusieurs jours de négociations pour
arriver jusqu'au siège de ce parti qui
représente en jordanie le conseil
national irakien une nouvelle ère se
lève pour l'irak titre leur journal
distribué sous le manteau
tous ici sont des opposants de longue
date à saddam hussein traditionnellement
exilé à londres ou aux états unis
ils se sont rapprochés de leur frontière
espérant que leur heure est enfin arrivé
nous avons des relais dans l'armée dans
les tribus au sein du parti baas notre
direction centrale a regagné l'irak il y
a quelques jours nos éléments tente de
convaincre la population que la chute de
saddam et irréversible cette fois-ci
impossible de voir leur radio
clandestine
nos interlocuteurs ont trop peur de la
police secrète de saddam hussein bien
infiltré en jordanie ou encore de la
police jordanienne elle même qui les
surveillent quotidiennement de cette
voiture grise dans un café rencontre
avec d'autres opposants irakiens
certains refusent de nous parler par
principe la france ne suivant pas les
etats-unis dans la guerre ils sont
journalistes anciens officiers médecins
et un peu amer que leurs compatriotes ne
profitent pas de la crise pour se
soulever les américains ont laissé
saddam réprimer le soulèvement chiite de
1991 il y a eu quatre cent mille morts
alors aujourd'hui s'il ya résistance de
la population
c'est pas par amour pour saddam hussein
c'est pour faire payer cet abandon aux
américains dans ce quartier populaire où
vivent des travailleurs immigrés
irakiens
on goûte peu le discours de l'opposition
l'opposition c'est un groupe de
mercenaires des traîtres qui vivent dans
des hôtels de londres ou de washington
qui sont payés par les américains où
sont-ils en ce moment un diviser la
communauté irakienne est à l'image des
ambiguïtés du gouvernement jordanien
alignée sur les états unis
le pouvoir doit ménager l'opposition
iranienne en exil mais ce soutien doit
rester discret dans un pays où la
majorité palestinienne et les centaines
de milliers de travailleurs immigrés
crient leur fidélité à saddam hussein
autres pays frontaliers avec l'irak la
syrie on a eu la confirmation tout à
l'heure que cinq syriens ont été tués et
dix autres blessés lors d'une erreur de
tir américaines ou britanniques c'est un
autocar venant d'irak et qui s'apprêtait
à franchir
là
on tiers avec abord beaucoup de
voyageurs rentrant chez eux qui a été
touché et puis une crise dans la crise
est peut-être en train de s'ouvrir entre
washington et moscou la maison blanche a
en effet affirmé avoir des preuves
concrètes que des entreprises russes
avaient récemment livré des armes à
l'irak le kremlin rejette ces
accusations
la guerre en irak qui s'est invitée à la
cérémonie des oscars
la nuit dernière à hollywood actrice en
noir badge pacifistes et diatribe contre
george bush
marie-jo juin nous sommes contre cette
guerre monsieur bush
honte à vous monsieur bush honte à vous
de toute façon même le pape est contre
vous vous êtes fini certains en rêvent
et d'autre le redoute et michael moore
oscars du documentaire a osé le faire en
45 secondes son temps de parole
violemment premier à rompre le silence
recommandé aux stars en retour des
sifflets ou des applaudissements selon
profitant de la vague
pedro almodovar oscar du scénario
original parle avec elle a dédié son
prix à tous ceux qui prennent la parole
en faveur de la paix autre surprise les
hausses cas du pianiste oscar du
meilleur acteur pour adrian brody
les yeux réalisateur roman polanski
absent parce qu'interdites séjour aux
états unis depuis 1977 plus policé le
discours d' adrian brody que l'on croit
en dieu ou allah
s'il vous plaît priez pour la paix et
une résolution rapide de cette guerre
d'autres encore comme susan sarandon
john harbour et discrètement et pin's
une colombe de la paix méconnaissable en
virginia woolf nicole kidman meilleure
actrice de stephen daldry annoncé le
retour d'un hollywood tout en strass et
paillettes avec l'oscar du meilleur film
pour chicago
pas vraiment une surprise vu
l'investissement des studios miramax à
l'image de cette cérémonie maintenu
coûte que coûte
b nay fox et puis un peu partout dans le
monde les manifestations anti guerre se
sont poursuivies notamment en allemagne
ici ou vingt mille étudiants s'étaient
rassemblés pour une marche à hambourg
des affrontements assez rude vous le
voyez ont eu lieu avec les forces de
l'ordre avant de refermer ce chapitre
consacré à la guerre en irak nous allons
au koweït
retrouvez en direct de philippe rochot
bonsoir philippe pour des précisions
peut-être concernant sept explosions
signalées à marennes près d'une base
américaine
écoutez pas de confirmation s'il s'agit
d'un accident ou d'un attentat
en revanche il y avait eu des menaces
ces derniers temps beaucoup de
manifestations aussi autour de cette
base de joux fait rire où s'est produite
l'explosion
et c'est important parce que c'est de là
que les américains en barque sur les
porte-avions donc jusque là là là l'île
de bahreïn affiché un profil bas ne
voulais pas montrer que les des en fait
les américains mais bien entendu il y
avait beaucoup de protestations autour
de cette action de cette politique de
bahreïn il n'est pas écarté que ce soit
un attentat qui ressemble étrangement à
l'attentât de 1990 est attribuée à ben
laden a à dhahran ou dix huit militaires
américains avaient été tués
merci philippe et vous nous rappelez
bien entendu d'ici la fin de ce journal
si vous avez d'autres précisions encore
un mot si vous êtes si vous suivez cette
guerre en irak un mot sur la position
française avec un rendez-vous complément
d'enquêté ce soir au sommaire notamment
reportage sur les relations entre george
bush et chirac compléments d'enquêté qui
sera exceptionnellement en direct avec
pour la première fois depuis le début de
la guerre une interview de dominique de
villepin le chef de la diplomatie
française à suivre donc à partir de
22h50 avec benoît duquesne le reste de
l'actualité de ce lundi 24 mars c'est
d'abord ce référendum contesté en
tchétchénie la nouvelle constitution
préparé par moscou a recueilli plus de
90 % de oui on n'a pas encore les
résultats définitifs
la question de l'indépendance de la
tchétchénie est close déjà conclu
vladimir poutine
je rappelle qu aucun observateur
étranger n'avait été admis
assister au vote en france la lutte
contre le cancer c'était l'un des trois
grands chantiers promis par jacques
chirac lors de sa campagne c'est lui
même qui a annoncé les mesures dans
leurs grandes lignes 500 millions
d'euros sur cinq ans et une guerre
déclarée au tabac pour reprendre
l'expression du chef de l'état le détail
nathalie sapina claude barny la
cigarette ou une catastrophe sanitaire a
annoncé dans 20 ans le tabac pourrait
tuer 60000 personnes deux fois plus
qu'aujourd'hui priorité faire baisser de
30% le tabagisme des jeunes
pour cela la politique de la hausse des
prix sera poursuivie autre priorité le
dépistage en particulier celui du cancer
du sein
pour l'instant il n'est effectif que
dans cinquante cinq départements
il sera généralisée d'ici la fin de
l'année un mois d'attentes pour un
scanner un délai que le plan anti cancer
veut réduire la france va s'équiper de
plus de scanner et l'irm seul moyen pour
détecter certaines tumeurs apprendre que
l'on souffre d'un cancer
un moment difficile et trop souvent
négligée est donc prévu la création
d'une consultation spéciale danon du
diagnostic plus longue et remboursés
comme tel par la sécurité sociale pour
les associations de malades
ce plan représente un grand espoir la
parole présidentielle moi je pense
qu'aujourd'hui changeant la dimension
sociale les bases sociales des cancers
le bal a donné plus seuls 70 mesures 500
millions d'euros c'est plus qu'un plan
anti cancer c'est le grand chantier
présidentiel de jacques chirac un
établissement pratique depuis plusieurs
années une politique novatrice en ce
domaine la clinique sainte catherine à
avignon son personnel est soutenu et
formés par des psychiatres isabelle
quintard à la location donc vous avez
que prévu le 19 septembre
donc il y avait bien dans votre sein en
effet deux petits foyers de cellules
cancéreuses
le moment est toujours brutal l'annnonce
du diagnostic de cancer est toute la
difficulté pour le cancérologue et de
trouver les mots justes quand on sait
qu'on va avoir une consultation
difficile qu'on doit annoncer des
mauvaises nouvelles
et bien réfléchir un peu avant avec le
psychiatre sur la façon d'annoncer cette
mauvaise nouvelle ne peut que nous aider
et aider la patiente bien entendu à
entendre cette mauvaise nouvelle
la psychiatre écoute soutien chacun des
membres des personnels soignants tous un
jour ou l'autre se sont retrouvées dans
une impasse face aux patients incapables
de gérer ce trop plein d'émotions la
personne en lan complètement déboussolé
sachant pas où était sa vie qu'est ce
qu'elle va faire après parce qu'elle
doit porter la souffrance son mari sa
souffrance à elle je me suis enfui gelé
posé sur une chaise
je vais donner un café et je veux je
savais plus quoi s'était trouvé la plus
grosse émotion je dirais qu'il est
souvent verbales idée c'est au tour la
fin de vie et puis également souvent les
bastian agressif et parfois l'équipe ait
pris je dirais un petit peu en coin c1
on va dire entre la famille le patient
peut être parfois le bouc émissaire
parce que la maladie ne s'arrête pas aux
portes de l'hôpital la psychiatre est
aussi là pour tous ceux qui de près ou
de loin sont en contact avec la maladie
sans y avoir été préparé
et beaucoup de passion qui préfère
parler avec nous
on a l'impression déjà ce alors qu'un
certain moral et puis ça leur permet de
parler un petit peu de temps en temps
leur maladie peu à peu la psychologie
entre à l'hôpital avec derrière une
attente très forte des malades que le
corps médical soit un peu moins
technicien et un peu plusieurs social en
bref avec l'ouverture du 47e congrès de
la cgt
objectif affiché par bernard thibault un
million d'adhérents contre un peu moins
de 700 mille aujourd'hui
et puis la poursuite de des
transformations de la centrale qui doit
s'orienter selon lui vers un
syndicalisme de proposition et non plus
seulement de contestation il s'agit
également de couper définitivement le
lien avec le parti communiste la mairie
de marseille dans la tourmente ce soir
perquisitions tout à l'heure à l'hôtel
de ville cinq personnes placées en garde
à vue parmi elles le bras droit du maire
directeur de cabinet claude bertrand
il aurait usé de sa position en faveur
d'un autre table marseillais
explications sinding boudaoud et laurent
dit aujourd'hui pour aller à son bureau
l'homme de confiance de jean claude
gaudin est accompagné par les gendarmes
en claude bertrand a déjà passé la
matinée avec eux en garde à vue cette
fois il doit leur ouvrir tous ces
dossiers
le directeur de cabinet du maire de
marseille est soupçonné d'être intervenu
auprès de la justice en faveur d'une
personnalité de la vivre des soupçons
fondés sur plusieurs conversations
téléphoniques enregistrées par les
enquêteurs
dans ces conversations claude bertrand
promet de venir en aide au président du
port autonome de marseille poursuivi à
l'époque par la justice par quels moyens
mystère mais l'homme en rire ou alizée
et relaxer avant d'être condamné en
appel le plus proche collaborateur de
jean claude gaudin at il tenté
d'influencer le cours de la justice
les enquêteurs en sont convaincus pas le
maire de marseille
dans un communiqué il lui et réitère ce
soir sa confiance
mais claude bertrand devrait être mise
en examen pour trafic d'influencé
c'est au détour d'une enquête sur le
port de marseille que les gendarmes ont
pris dans leurs filets code bertrand
d'autres notables de la ville pourrait
suivre santé l'épidémie de pneumopathies
sa progression semble ralenti dernier
bilan 17 morts et près de 400 cas et un
premier cas probable en france il s'agit
d'un médecin qui revient d'hanoï
il a été hospitalisé à tourcoing sophie
mais elle nathalie satena c'est ici au
centre hospitalier de tourcoing qu'un
patient rentre entière du vietnam a été
admis il s'agit d'un médecin qui a
soigné des malades du sart ce le
syndrome respiratoire aigu sévère à
l'hôpital français de hanoi et qui
présente lui-même les premiers symptômes
de la maladie
c'est un cac est considéré comme très
probable
actuellement et donc nous en saurons un
peu plus d'un an prochain
bonjour mais nous faisons tout comme
s'il s'agissait d'un cas avéré parce
qu'il ya plusieurs critères qui
correspondent à un cas de pneumonie
atypique
l'hôpital français de hanoi est
justement le point de départ probable de
l'infection la moitié du personnel
soignant il a été contaminé
et bien que de nouvelles personnes soit
décédé aujourd'hui une infirmière et un
médecin vietnamien qui était placé
depuis plusieurs jours sous assistance
respiratoire
la situation semble à peu près sous
contrôle comme nous l'expliquent le
docteur fleury envoyés en renfort est
jointe sur place actuellement
citation qui sont encore quatre voies
d'amélioration quatre morts au vietnam
10 à hong kong 3 au canada
au total 17 décès liés à la maladie ont
été enregistrés mais près de 400
personnes sont encore malades à travers
le monde ont ce laboratoire dans 10 pays
travaillent à isoler le virus dont on
devrait connaître bientôt la carte
génétique
l'étape suivante devrait être la mise au
point d'un vaccin
sport football d'abord en rappel la 31e
journée de ligue 1 lyon a battu nice
hier soir 1-0 but signé julie niaux le
tenant du titre est maintenant troisième
au classement un point seulement
derrière les deux leaders monaco et
marseille
l'image du week-end après se
ralentissait têtière le championnat
espagnol le real madrid a battu la
corogne 2 0 qui a marqué zinedine zidane
auteur du premier but mais victime d'un
mauvais coups infligés par scaloni et le
champion français a dû quitter le
terrain
sa participation au match france malte
samedi prochain en éliminatoires de
l'euro n'est pas remise en cause dit on
au real et puis je vous rappelle
informations pratiques qu il ne vous
reste que quelques heures pour poster
votre déclaration d'impôt sur le revenu
2002 si vous ne l'avez pas encore fait
dernier délai ce soir minuit le cachet
de la poste faisant foi
avant de refermer ce journal une image
et puis nous irons à bagdad l'image
d'abord elle est importante c'est celle
du porc doom casseurs confirmation en
images donc que le port et bien
maintenant sous contrôle américain
attention il ne s'agit que du porc est
pas de la ville d'oum casseurs mais vous
savez que c'est le seul port en eau
profonde de cette pointe littoral de
l'irak et qui permettra donc d'acheminer
des renforts mais aussi de l'aide
humanitaire et on a entendu dans ce
journal que la situation humanitaire est
très critique en de nombreux points de
l'irak et notamment dans les grandes
villes à bassorah par exemple nous
allons avant de refermer ce journal à
bagdad retrouver alain de chalvron il
est 22 heures 50 à bagdad alain et c'est
vraisemblablement une nouvelle nuit de
bombardements qui s'annonce oui écouté
pendant ce temps de l'année il ya eu des
bombardements mais ça ne serait même pas
venu à l'idée d' interrompre le cours de
votre journal david pour redire car
c'est devenu d'une banalité stupéfiante
ces bombardements me semble-t-il ont été
dirigés sur la banlieue sud de la ville
ce qui n'est pas étonnant puisque les
troupes américaines arriveront par là et
naturellement une fois de plus se
vendent enfants étaient suivis du
déclenchement de la sirène d'alarmé qui
arrivent mais heureusement la plupart du
temps maintenant à contretemps merci
alain merci à vous d'avoir suivi cette
édition à suivre la météo patrice drevet
il fera encore très beau demain sur la
france 22h50 on joue rappelle complément
d'enquêté benoît duquesne la diplomatie
française pendant la crise avec une
interview de dominique de villepin
dernier journal 12h55 jean claude
renault dès 6h30 télématin dans les 4
vérités gérard leclerc recevra dominique
moïsi spécialiste des relations
internationales
à demain